(laughs)
- There's probably a lot of things
you wouldn't believe about me.
But I'm not sure I'm
willing to share them all.
(laughing)
This is kind of a
downer, but that I suffer
from severe depression.
Do I look like I do?
- [Thoraya] I mean, I
wouldn't have guessed it, no.
- No, that's why I'm over
here getting some sun.
It's something that I've
dealt with for nine years
after I retired as a nurse practitioner.
Because I sort of lost my compass.
I was a workaholic.
I just finished having 20 ECT,
electric convulsive shock
treatments, for my depression.
So what they do is they knock you out
with a short-term anesthetic
and they induce a convulsive
by running electric
current through your brain
which is something that I'd
never, ever thought I would do
as a healthcare provider.
But my depression was so bad
that I was willing to try anything.
So I tried it.
- I spent 10 years in the military.
You could probably can't tell, right?
- [Thoraya] (laughing) Right.
Are you pretty patriotic?
- You know, I was for a long time
but I dunno, some things kind
of changed after a while.
It's difficult to reconcile
like, a lot of the things
that the government's done.
You know, like my part in
it and stuff like that, so.
After a certain amount of
time, I dunno, I just started
to notice like, there was a trend.
Like, the things that I was saying
and the things that
other people were saying,
the way that it affected people.
It started to make me
really feel uncomfortable.
And I think there's a lot
of sexism in the military
and I think that's the main thing
that I'm guilty of, personally, is...
I dunno, we were taught to dislike women.
I can't like, explain it in a logical way.
It didn't make sense and it still,
it doesn't make sense now
but at the time, I was trying
to buy all these other
dudes who were doin' it,
and so it just felt right.
I just said bad things about
other women in my unit.
They were marines, they were
just as qualified as I was.
But it was wrong and it's
scary how easy it was, though.
You know?
It's scary how easy,
how sometimes you just
don't even notice the bad
things you do, you know?
Until suddenly you do.
I don't know, I feel like a **** creep.
- [Thoraya] What's something that
I wouldn't believe about you?
- I actually love the junkyard
and I'm fixin' up a car.
Like, we tore the whole
inside apart and so, yeah,
I really, I love going in a junkyard
and just taking off a part of the stuff.
- [Interviewer] Why do you think people
wouldn't believe that about you?
- Because I look very clean.
And you get really dirty in the junkyard.
And it's hot, it's so hot, oh my god.
But it's so fun.
I like fixing things and I love
giving things another meaning.
And I think a lot of cars,
like, people take for granted.
Like, the car I'm fixing
up and the car I have now,
like, even if she broke down
or if people wanna buy it
sometimes, like, I would never sell it.
I don't know, I talk to the
car sometimes. (laughing)
Maybe they're like people to me.
Like my little kid.
- [Thoraya] So when
you go to the junkyard,
do you just see like, a bunch of people?
- No, I see a bunch of cars. (laughing)
I think of them as girls.
So I'll be like, when you
finally take off something
'cause it's really hard to
unscrew everything, okay?
So you just, it's really
hard to take off the stuff.
And you take it off,
you're like, "Heck yeah,
"you got this, girl," like you did it.
Like that, I'd be telling the car that.
I'd be like, "Just wait, just wait.
"I'm gonna get you something new."
Like, "Don't worry,
we're gonna fix you up."
- [Thoraya] Do you
truly feel such a connection
to your car?
- Yeah, I truly feel,
I feel like everything I have
you should really care about.
You should always take care of your things
and I feel bad for people who have things
that they don't take care of,
or have all these
opportunities and they don't,
you know, use them wisely.
Yeah, I do all kinds of things.
I'm crazy.
I'm really smart in school.
I was a straight A student.
I was a runner.
I was varsity what everything,
I could go to a big school.
I had a whole bunch of scholarships,
you know, like, almost full ride.
But I didn't go to university.
And that's because I think
I could do something else.
- [Thoraya] I really think so too,
and I'm not just saying that.
You don't necessarily
know what you're gonna do
but you know--
- I just know I'm gonna do something good.
And I think everyone
can do something good.
- Something you wouldn't believe about me?
Help me out, guys.
What would you not believe about me?
- [Thoraya] Wait, say that again.
- (laughing) That he's a lady's man.
He's got game but he just
doesn't show it to anybody.
His game will come out
whenever he wants it to.
- It's all a slow and
steady process, you know?
Ain't no rush.
- Something that you wouldn't
believe about me is that
my heart is backwards.
It hasn't caused any like, health problems
or anything like that,
it's just backwards.
- That I was on my high
school wrestling team.
- I'm scared of needles.
- I have never had a cup
of coffee in my life.
- I'm transgender.
- That I've a twin brother that's
all tattooed just like me.
- I can speak, read,
and write fluent Spanish
'cause I'm Latino.
But, you know, on the outside
it really doesn't look like it
so people are always shocked
when I speaking fluent Spanish.
- You wouldn't believe that I'm
not a fluent Spanish speaker.
'Cause I'm obviously very Latino
and I think that's why you
probably wouldn't guess it.
I don't, I don't speak Spanish.
Not fluently, at least.
- Something that you
wouldn't believe is that
I'm not Indian.
People think I look Indian, but I'm not.
I'm actually Spanish.
- So everybody thinks I'm
really nice and really friendly.
They say that, but I
really like shooting guns.
I really like violence.
I love punching things, kicking things,
throwing things at people.
I slap my friends for fun.
I choke them sometimes.
Yeah, all in good fun though.
It actually works out for
me because I like playing
off this, I'm a sweet Asian
girl, that kind of thing.
So nobody really ever suspects me.
And then I just come outta nowhere.
I'm like, feisty. (laughing)
So it kind of a fun, it's fun for me.
- Something you wouldn't believe about me.
So I did OnlyFans for my, after
I turned 18 on my birthday
and I found out that my
PE teacher followed me
on my OnlyFans and didn't know it was me
'cause my face was not shown at all.
And I saw him every single
day, so it was really funny
knowing that he followed me.
- I was born on a bus.
I was premature, I was born at six months.
And my mom didn't know she was pregnant
and she was taking the bus to work.
And her water broke and
she got really bad cramps
and I just slipped out.
Now I'm here.
(laughing) Yeah.
Brutal but, yeah.
- [Thoraya] Your
mom didn't have no idea
she was pregnant?
- Mm-mm.
She wasn't even showing or nothing.
Whenever I ask her about this
story, she always tells me
like, it was really hard
for her to understand
what was going on because
she hadn't had her,
she hadn't had her period in a while.
But she had already gotten her
tubes tied and so she thought
it just wasn't something
that could happen.
And she's on the bus to
work and all of a sudden,
she got really bad cramps
and felt something coming out over there.
And then everybody else on
the bus starts freaking out
and she got rushed to the hospital.
And so she always calls
me like, a miracle.
- I guess it's like, how
much grip religion has
on me, still, even after
labeling myself as an atheist.
Just because being born
into a religious family,
like, it had so much power over my life
and I only recently got out of it.
I just started college
and I finally was able
to get away from my home, my family
who's really, really religious.
I was finally able to
take a break from church
and it feels very freeing.
However, religion has definitely possessed
a very strong grip on me.
And whatever decision I make
and whatever action I take,
even when I shouldn't, it's like even now.
Like, what I'm wearing
isn't revealing at all,
however, in some parts, I'm like,
should I be exposing my arms?
And when I do something with
another person, it's like,
should I really be doing this?
Will this make me go to hell?
Like, is this the right choice to make?
It definitely is a struggle.
- I don't think you would
believe that I'm like,
really vengeful, like, extremely vengeful
just 'cause a lot of people see me
as really sweet, which I am.
But when you cross me,
like, I'll make sure
that I ruin your life.
And I've literally gotten
vengeance on anybody
who's ever traumatized me.
And like, every single one of my ex's
that have cheated on me,
like, their life went to ****.
So, vengeance.
In that type of sense, yeah,
it does make me feel better
when I see like, especially
'cause they never know
I was behind it.
So basically, I was dating
this guy for like, two years.
Long story short, he got really drunk
and he was acting really
weird and suspicious,
and like, reminding of the other time
my other ex cheated on me.
And so he left his phone unlocked.
I went through it and saw
that he was cheating on me,
like, two days before we went
to Disneyland with my family.
And so then I messaged the
girl pretending to be him
and like, basically told her like, yeah,
we just hooked up, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
He was like, in love with
this girl, apparently.
And then yeah, I like,
ruined chances between them
because he was my boyfriend.
And like, she just hated him after that.
And like, he woke up the next day
and he's like, "Did we get
in a fight last night?"
I was like, "No, why?"
He's like, "My friend Jessica
isn't talking to me anymore."
And I was like, "I don't know
what you're talking about."
And, like, I remember we
still went to Disneyland
'cause I faked it out with my family.
And he had the nerve to
cry over like, a song.
Like, tear up because
the girl that he loved
wasn't talking to him anymore.
So yeah, and he has no
idea that I'm the reason
that he can't have this
girl that he wants.
So stuff like that, I guess.
Just like, thought out,
planned kind of thing.
I was also married and my
husband was cheating on me.
And like, brat girls, over and stuff.
And so I slept with his
best friend in our bed.
And then I just kept
like, cheating on him,
like, over and over to
just show him how I felt.
And like, the marriage fell apart.
We were really getting a divorce.
I mean, I'm no better
because I did it back,
but like, I don't regret it.
I don't 'cause I'm like.
- [Thoraya] Have you ever
thought to yourself, like,
"Actually, I don't feel better," or?
- When I'd be having sex
with somebody else, like,
I'd be like what am I
really getting out of this?
Like, not only is my husband using me
but like, so is this dude.
Like, he doesn't care about me.
Then I just kinda feel
lonely and stuff like that.
These days, I let just
god handle vengeance.
I feel like it played out a lot better.
There are times where
I'm like, really tempted
to do something to somebody that hurts me
but I'm just really tired of the karma.
Just 'cause it comes
back to me every time.
Like, there's never been a time
where I didn't get it back.
You know?
So, yeah.
- I don't think that a lot
of people would believe
that I was in a women's jail,
detention center, prisoner.
Arrested for domestic
violence against a woman
that I was in a relationship with.
I pulled a knife out and
threatened her with it.
And it cost me a lot of things in my life.
The humiliation, the shame
behind it was something
that I still carry with me.
But I was able to make amends for it.
The other thing is that
I was drunk and on drugs
when that happened and that
I'm now clean and sober.
Now I've turned my life around.
And I am happy, joyous, and free.
And my life is such a blessing.
And I'm super happy.
- Hey everyone, Thor.Aya, here.
I wanted to say thank you
for watching this episode.
I am still selling these
sweaters on my website.
If you're interested, I'll link in
in my description.
I love you guys and
I'll see you next week.
(soft music)